انضم الينا من بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه العميد الياس حنا اهلا بك
عميد الياس بالاضافه للتطورات في جبهات
القتال
المستمره هناك تطور لافت مرتبط بوصول
المسيرات الاوكرانيه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
الى العمق الروسي فيروستوف وسماره امس ما
الذي يشير اليه ذلك
مريم هناك ديناميكيه معينه او مومنتم معين
لهذه الحرب هي ليست المره الاولى المسيرات
وصلت الى قواعد جويه مهمه في انجلز على
سبيل المثال وهي بعيده جدا عن الحدود
الاوكرانيه فيها اهداف ذات قيمه
استراتيجيه القذيفات الاستراتيجيه الروسيه
هي وصلت الى الكريم الى محيط موسكو نحن من
ضمن هذه العمليه لنقل الحرب الى الداخل
الروسيه وازعاج روسيه على انها او ما يسمى
او اظهارها على ان امنها هش جدا فاذا هذه
العمليات هي صحيح لها صوره معينه ولكنها
لا تنهي الحرب يعني ما يجري
فعلا او الذي يحسم الحرب هو
هي رده فعل هي امر يدل ان هناك اصبحت
امكانيات مهمه يعني الصناعات الحربيه
الاوكرانيه تحدث الطائرات المسيرات وهذا
امر مهم جدا الكثافه بسبب كثافه الحرب
التي تجري على خط جبهه مريم يقارب 900 كم
معين من مخموت حيث هناك تقدم الى منطقه
زبالوجيا الى منطقه الجنوبيه هذا الامر
مهم جدا هذه العمليات هي عمليه الا ولكنها
لا تؤثر كثيرا على سير العمليات التكتيكيه
على الارض فعلا ما الذي يمكن ان نفهمه مما
يقوله البولنديون الان هم يقولون ان الوضع
على الحدود
الاكثر خطوره بعد تحرك اكثر من 100 مسلح
من فاجنر نحو من مر سوالكي
عثمان ممر سوالكي يعود الى ايام الحرب
البارده وهو دائما كان منطقه الهشه
لبولندا مع بيلاروسيا اذا قطعت من
بيلاروسيا هذا الممر تصل مباشره الى القسم
الروسي على بحر البلطيق هذا امر قديم جدا
اليوم عندما نتحدث عن حرب بهذا الحجم
ونتحدث عن مئه مقاتل فقط من فاجنر لا
يمتلك السلاح لا يمتلك الطيران هي مؤشر هي
تحذير مسبق ولكن ليس هناك من خطوره مهمه
كما يحدث في اوكرانيا يعني باوكرانيا قتل
ما يقارب عشرين الف
مقاتل من في في مخمود اليوم نتحدث عن 100
مقاتل اتوا حديثا الى بيلاروسيا ليسوا
مجهزين ولا يريدون فتح جبهه معينه ولكن
هذا الامر هذا الممر هو مهم ذات قيمه
استراتيجيه كبيره لروسيا
ولبولندا من بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العميد الياس حنا شكرا جزيلا
لك